arrival at the Berlin bus station is  often the starting point for Bulgarians  and Romanians looking for work they see  it as a final hurdle many Germans are  skeptical if the only people who come  are those who want to work well that's  great  but you're always reading about those  who've showed up just to skim benefits a  boy yes it means just people trying to  build a good life  not everyone ought to just turn up more  than half of Germans are concerned about  the immigrants gaining full access to  the labour market 1/3 are less concerned  just 11% are completely unconcerned but  some point out the benefits emigration  brings via we really need people in the  IT industry right now so I think it's  pretty good parties like the CSU are  just out to make people panic I think it  won't be all that bad I'm sure Germany  will survive it understand Cadiz  Deutschland via dissolve  you